yeah you've told that story about a
thousand I know I know because I know
you have it was a dark and stormy night
when the werewolves allowed Addison to
join them around the sacred fire pit and
Addison did her best to ask them
questions and the werewolves did their
best to avoid answering them
wolf tails might have left zombies fans
in the dark but it did hint towards
their bingo zombies three keep watching
for everything you missed in the Disney
special and watch until the end to find
out if the a in Addison stands for alpha
wolf or alien one of the first clues for
zombies three is dropped by Addison at
the very beginning of the special the
werewolves have voted and Addison is
allowed to join them around the fire pit
but she doesn't yet know what the sacred
space is called so she takes a few wild
guesses and it's safe to assume that
they aren't random first Addison calls
the fire pit a moon circle which could
be a hint that zombies three will indeed
have something to do with aliens then
Addison calls the fire pit a star space
which is yet another clue that the three
quill will have something to do with
outer space
lastly Addison guesses that the fire pit
is called the howl area which is an
amalgamation of the words howl and
planetarium her third guest pretty much
confirms that xiii will welcome aliens
into the mix after all why would a
descent assume that the wolves fire pit
was a space-themed the 6-minute dizzy
special doesn't waste any time when it
comes to drop includes the next one is
brought to us by winter who tells
Addison that coming to the fire pit is a
rite of passage for all werewolves
coming here is a rite of passage for all
we're bored
but wait last time we checked Odyssey
wasn't a werewolf so what is she doing
at the fire pit
besides roasting s'mores of course will
it chime soon to say that Addison was
allowed to visit the fire pit because
she earned it she also reveals that the
Wolves took a vote which is why Addison
was brought to the pit in the first
place clearly the wolves want to thank
Addison for saving them in zombies too
but is that the only reason why Addison
has joined them or is there something
else going on behind the scenes why
would they bring Addison
such a magical and sacred place if she
wasn't in the running to become a
werewolf keep watching to find out come
with us
what's so important you are we already
know how the zombies were created they
sprung to life after a plant explosion
but we have no idea where the moonstone
comes from the werewolves nervously
changed the subject
every time Addison asked us about the
moonstone and how it came to be this got
us thinking do the werewolves actually
know the answer to these questions are
they calling it a werewolf secret
instead of admitting that no one knows
where the moonstone came from either way
these unanswered questions will most
likely be answered when zombies 3
becomes a reality
what does Christophe from frozen have in
common with Wyatt from zombies - well
first of all they both know what it
feels like to be lost in the woods and
secondly they have both seen something
magical happened that they couldn't
quite explain for Christophe that was
watching the trolls use magic to heal
honor and for Wyatt that was being
attacked by a scary creature that turned
out to be a school bag did we mention
that both of these stories happened on a
dark and stormy night anyway Wyatt's
story has a few holes in it but we'll
point out the most obvious one there's
just no way why it would get spooked by
his backpack he's a mighty wolf
emphasized why would he repeat that
embarrassing story if he hadn't truly
been attacked by something in the woods
did anyone notice that the monster
attacking him looked a lot like a white
werewolf or that the monsters white fur
had a hint of blue to it at the
beginning of Wyatts story we can see a
full moon in the night skies so could it
be that there's an actual werewolf who
transforms on the full moon living in
Seabrook and is this werewolf the Alpha
aka Addison keep watching to find out
in zombies - Zoe drops a little red
riding-hood reference when she looks at
Wyatt and says what big eyes you have
but in the Disney special wolf tails
Wyatt and winter also referenced the
ancient fairy tale
Wyatt tells the story of being lost in
the woods where as winter tells Addison
about one of her ancestors getting us
born stuck in her foot winter goes on to
say that the thorn caused her ancestor
to howl for the very first time she also
explains how this incident caused the
wolves to become excellent singers well
both the Wyatt and winter statements can
be traced back to the fairy tale
first of all Little Red Riding Hood had
to cross the long-lost wood to get to
her grandma's house and second of all
Little Red Riding Hood stepped on a
thorn and received help from a hooded
creature who disappeared before she
could see his face which is what
happened to Wyatt when he got lost in
the woods if there's one thing fans
immediately noticed it's satin said
wasn't in the Disney special according
to Willa Addison earned her spot around
the fire pit but in the end it was said
who saved the day by using his zombie
strength to save the moonstone so why
wasn't he at the fire pit with Addison
on a side note did anyone notice that
there were sparks flying between Addison
and Wyatt in the Disney short tell us
which couple you ship most in the
comments
Zedan Addison or Addison and Wyatt
before we reveal what wolf tails means
for zombies three
let's talk plot holes during why it's
story he reveals that he used to
scavenge around human campsites for
goods but in zombies too it was revealed
that the werewolves had lived in the
Forbidden Forest for centuries and
humans weren't allowed to set foot in
that forest so why would they be camping
there in the first place then Willa
reveals that she snuck out of the forest
and into a nearby town to grab some food
on her way home
however Willa gets trapped in the store
for the night dance quickly notice that
we'll have paid for a bag of chips using
human money which she shouldn't have had
access to problem is Willa ate half the
store and never paid for any of those
items so why did she pay for the chips
in the first place did you spot any more
plot holes tell us in the comments
Addison had three great questions to ask
her werewolf friends but instead of
answering them wyatt Willa and winter
each took turns telling campfire stories
by the end of the special Addison
realizes that she's not going to get any
answers
Willa tells Addison that they can never
reveal their secrets to someone who
isn't a werewolf unless they choose to
become one any of my questions
but when Addison points out what Willa
just said she immediately changes the
subject
she tells Addison that it's getting late
and that they should go home when at
first the wolves had said that they had
all night to answer Addison's questions
do you think Addison will become a
werewolf if given the choice in zombies
three
[Music]
werewolf tails ended on a cliffhanger
just like zombies - and it left us with
tons of questions but while the specials
didn't give us much to go on
fans did notice that some of the wolves
looked a little different
winters hair is a lot shorter in wolf's
tails than it is in zombies - and Wyatt
in Willa's hair looks a little different
- we also noticed that Addison is
wearing her hair like the wolves do
despite not being a werewolf after her
moonstone necklace failed the Lyta
Addison reverted back to her normal look
but in the special she's all wolf doubt
could this be yet another clue that
Addison will become a werewolf in the
three quo or was her hair done up that
way to match the overall look of wolf
tails we know that Disney Channel
designers like to switch things up so we
can definitely expect to see our
favorite characters rocking some brand
new looks in zombies 3 at the end of
zombies - a blue meteor falls from the
sky and lands outside of Seabrook
causing Addison's clock to go berserk
there seems to be a connection between
the blue moonstone and time which is
something Wyatt talks about in wolf's
tails before being cut off by Addison
Wyatt recalls a story where he lost
track of time he then goes on to say
that time is a flat circle could this be
a hint that time will be affected in
zombies 3 tell us what you think in the
comments
[Music]
alliteration plays a pivotal role in the
zombies naming game
we know that the werewolves all have
names that start with the letter W and
we know that the zombies have names that
either start with the letter Z or
contain the letter Z but what does that
mean for Addison
since the moonstone comes from outer
space and Addison has unique and magical
hair it's possible that her bloodline
has alien DNA in it but could werewolves
also share the same DNA there's a theory
that Addison is the white wolf we see
attacking Wyatt in the forest on the
full moon unlike Wyatt Willa and winter
Addison isn't a werewolf
she's a breed of her own which could be
why the moonstone necklace temporarily
lit up or her
Addison's hair lit up like a moonstone
when the unidentified blue object came
crashing down from the sky if the
werewolves get their power and
immortality from the moonstone they
could be connected to aliens in more
ways than one
Addison could very well be the alpha
wolf they've been searching for she did
help them save the moonstone like the
prophecy predicted after all we'll find
out where the moonstone comes from
sooner than later
but for now we're sticking with our
theory that the a in Addison stands for
alpha wolf and that's a wrap do you
think that the werewolves actually know
where the moonstone came from or are
they lying to Addison so they don't come
off as clueless tell us your theories in
the comments thanks for watching for
more fun content be sure to subscribe to
the things and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up we'll see you next
time
you